hey guys so today uh we're at
entertainment tonight right now where's
jenna there you are
so we're about to get hair and makeup
done francesca's on her way i'm super
excited so make sure you guys watch it's
gonna be hold on i don't want to screw
up the time all of the info is in the
description so i'm pretty pumped because
we're doing a recap on everything that
happened at comic-con and
i get to be a part of it this would be
so cool yeah yeah i also i don't know if
they're gonna let me do it but on the
way here
i thought it would be really cool to
make a vine dancing
on the entertainment tonight desk
it would be like not really like a real
real dance but like uh something
oh look who's here
don't shut my hair my hair doesn't look
good
antennae
oh you got your case on it's my favorite
case ever i got so many comments oh my
gosh this girl right here
so what time what time does everybody
walk we take your local listings but
it's um in new york it's at 7 30 and in
l.a it's at 7 30. so but across the
country it's different times so
everybody else in the middle you got to
figure it out join it's really fun i'm
really excited so on the way here i was
telling my sister i wanted to dance on
the desk is that possible yeah wait this
way okay
wait you want to dance on a desk yeah
for a while on the et desk no well
you'll have to ask maybe you can ask
nancy okay i will have to put my pants
back on because i don't want to wear a
dress
where are we going right now you're
going into the pretty the talent meeting
okay so you're going to be with brad
our executive producer yeah um nancy or
nancy and rob marciano awesome so are
they okay with vlogging
they're okay with vlogging maybe not the
whole meeting okay but maybe they just
say hi
maybe you can like say hello to
everybody are you sure you go first i'm
scared
i have no makeup on either so we're just
like you look pretty
uh i'll see you guys later cheers
hi again
so we're about to go on i've got some
scripts we've got the look at this it's
actually really high up there look i
know where you are
yeah oh you've already established that
i was in here you know it's okay but
these cameras are a lot bigger than mine
big not as big
all right you ready
you're very pretty thank you you look
very pretty oh thank you i'm here today
jessica you look very pretty
coming up right after the news at 6
entertainment tonight
trustee
let's wait for some better light just
hold on a second come on up here and
shoot yeah much better
that's it
that's six seconds
uh i was a little free to dance on the
desk and i don't think i was able to
hold me but i danced on the stage so now
i'm gonna go do some something else
something something else if you want to
rewrite this like in your own words like
unless you're cool with that do you want
to roll through it first before we
actually record or do you want to just
go for it framing at all oh um
that's how i try clothesline in the
dressing rooms too lazy
okay we're good
here's a look at the epicness including
my selfie if it has been making news
around the world
perfect awesome yeah
so then all i need last but not least
our videos from you okay we'll do it
right here
oh yeah of course
blended everything in bold and that's
just the thing
this is coming out of um
guys i got a little treat bag look at
this
i have my own e.t hoodie too bad it's
like 800 degrees out here but i'm still
gonna wear it anyway
i'm so fancy
in the fast lane from elena tokyo i know
all the work
um so yeah make sure you guys watch
tonight i'm super excited i had so much
fun
uh ichi's awesome they were so much fun
i love you guys
i'm sweat i'm sweating